we have come here today from the
presence of God and these witnesses to
join in holy matrimony Martin and
Philippe oh these aren't these are your
real names it's just that this is what
you guys gave me
that's the donor of the internet or
something it's a template yeah yeah
you're supposed to cross out their names
in patterning well that's not what I was
hired to do used to do proofreading
right I mean it's all good it's just I'm
most sure that's not all I know who you
are I'm just saying that you gave me
something it says Martin and Felipe just
say our name this is a valley bunch not
Felipe right Martin and Felipe that's
two guys that doesn't make sense Martin
in but I could fix it I'm just saying I
wanted like a carrot top impersonator at
least I don't know I mean I am a carrot
top impersonator
yeah props okay that's a stick I think
we should start because we actually are
paying by the hour so if we get out of
here within a 15 minute increments aid
money it's building our 30 minute
sequences so even if you get out no 15
minutes you're still gonna pay the half
an hour rate so you may as well relax
and enjoy this Moshe will you have
Natasha to be your lawful wedded wife
will you love her comfort her keep her
in sickness and in health and forsaking
all others be faithful to her for as
long as you both shall live and Natasha
I hope that we don't answer Yasmine it's
a rhetorical question he has a problem
with the sickness part what do you have
no I don't have anything but I think
he's scared that if something did happen
you will get sick
I guarantee not from this but just in
general there's a lot of germs and you
do need to wash your hands after using
the toilet that's what I'm saying that's
not what I've been trying to tell you
and just some of the food you know I
don't know what kind of oil it is the
main issue well I mean it's not so much
the toilet but the people that are
preparing food that these restaurants
didn't wash their hands from the toilet
so what'd you do in the toilet sort of
irrelevant as you're eating you know
eggs or what have you and it's not
prepared in a sanitary
weighing toilet oh that's part of this
that's yeah no well that should
digression Filipa Natasha Natasha will
you have Martin air motion Moshe to be
your lawful wedded husband will you love
him comfort and keep him in sickness
this sickness and in health and
forsaking all others be faithful to him
so long as you both shall live this is
messed up I'm sorry yeah
this ring no we have the Rings
yeah we're skip the Rings we just renew
all their this this they needed to edit
that okay i moshe i moshe take you to
take you Natasha Natasha to be to be my
wife my wife to have to have and to hold
and to hold from this day forward from
this day forward for better or worse for
better or worse for richer and richer or
poorer for richer ample not average or
that was my moral or poor that was my
mistake in sickness and in health in
sickness and in health
except for that toilet thing to love and
to cherish to love and to cherish till
death do us part till death do us part
all right you're done all right Natasha
I Natasha I Natasha take you Moshe take
you Moshe to be my husband to have and
to hold and wait until I give the line
and then you repeat the line I can't
talk over each other do you start over
no I think no if you wouldn't keep him
but he's right actually from this day
forward from this day forward for better
or for worse for better or for worse for
richer or for poorer richer or for
poorer in sickness
health in sickness but I don't want to
do the sickness thing if you're not
gonna do it I mean you just it's a woman
to just read the line yeah just do it
but that toilet no just do it do it
that's it because you guys you only have
a couple more minutes with a chapel so
that these sort of digressions would you
would have to bump you into the overtime
which is I don't n dollars per minute I
don't know ten dollars per minute
amounts than that in sickness and in
health
okay we're done here thank you okay yeah
you're officially remarried and have a
great stay just or whatever
good luck guys good luck
you keep playing summer as we walk out
we got another
he told me I had a little surprise
coming in the mail okay
Hitachi Magic Wand
he bought me that wand quick
grill